this delegation from the organization
for security and cooperation in europe
was the first to visit the crash site on
friday night
but pro-russian separatists who control
the area
only allowed them limited access
debris from the downed boeing 777 is
scattered over an area of 25 square
kilometers
kiev wants the rebels to leave the area
but the separatists say they're staying
to ensure the investigation is impartial
u.s president barack obama has called
for an immediate investigation
he says moscow is responsible for the
continuing conflict in eastern ukraine
that led to the downing of a civilian
plane over the last several weeks
russian-backed separatists have shot
down a ukrainian transport plane
and a ukrainian helicopter and they
claimed responsibility for shooting down
a ukrainian
fighter jet moreover we know that these
separatists have
received a steady flow of support from
russia
russia for its part says kiev is
responsible
at a meeting with leaders of the russian
orthodox church president vladimir putin
called for a ceasefire
all sides of the conflict have to stop
military action immediately
and start peace talks all of us should
aim for that
and ask the patriarch for help in this
matter
australia which lost 28 nationals in the
crash
called for russia's full cooperation on
saturday
his prime minister said anyone who
obstructed an international independent
investigation
was no friend of peace quite possibly
there are attempts in place to sanitize
the site
the site needs to be secured the
investigation needs to take place
a malaysian team has arrived in kiev to
help with that
investigation
you